all right in this video I want to talk a
little bit about the lineweaver-burk
plot and also called rather not the end
the also called the double reciprocal
plot okay
so in the last two videos I mentioned
the hyperbolic equation and I'm going to
write it down here again and it was V
equals V Max times the substrate
concentration over km plus the substrate
concentration and I mentioned that if
you know the substrate course you know
the v-max in the km you just plug in a
substrate concentration and get the
velocity but this was a hyperbolic
equation and I don't know about you guys
but back when I took math and I first
learned hyperbolas I was scared to death
because they're scary they're tough to
deal with they're annoying to deal with
they're not as easy as some other things
in math but um what we can do is you can
transform this a hyperbolic equation is
something much easier to work with so
let's do that so if we if we do this if
we involve this idea of a double
reciprocal we're going to take both of
these values the V and then whole value
here and reciprocate them right flip
them over so one divided by velocity and
one divided by this whole thing this
thing just gets flipped over so what we
end up getting is we get 1 over the
velocity equals the km plus the
substrate concentration over v-max times
the substrate concentration and now what
I'm going to do to manipulate it further
is to separate this because this km and
substrate concentration both have this
common denominator so what I can do is
say km over the v-max times 1 over the
substrate concentration you'll see that
I separated that and you'll see why in
just a moment plus the substrate
concentration over v-max times the
substrate concentration what we have now
is we can simplify this portion here by
knocking off these substrate
concentrations because they cancel out
and then what we end up being left with
is the following we get
1 over V equals km times V map portion
that's km times of you guys km over
v-max times 1 over the substrate
concentration plus or left with here
which is 1 over the v-max so now this
thing here is an important equation it's
specifically called the lineweaver-burk
equation and some of you probably
already see why this thing is awesome
relative to the hyperbolic equation and
the reason why is because it's a line
right this is y equals MX plus B that's
actually the reason I separated this 1
over s out so now what we're doing is if
we can plot this line on a on a you know
a plane and you know where Y will the Y
values will be able to 1 over the
velocity of the reaction and 1 over the
substrate concentration will be the X
values so let's actually see how that
would look so that would look a little
something like this let's see if I can
make this as neat as possible and of
course I can't make it that great but it
will do anyway we're only going to be
concerned with the first two quadrants
because our lines sort of look like this
I have an x intercept and a y-intercept
and these so this is the y intercept
here and this is the x intercept here
and the reason why I noted those
particular points is because they're
they're particularly of importance the y
axis like I mentioned is 1 over 1 over V
so we got 1 over V here and the x axis
is 1 over the substrate concentration
right which makes sense right if it's
the double double reciprocal plot this
is coming from that initial graph that
we drew where we plotted velocity on the
y axis and substrate concentration on
the x axis so here we just flip them
both over and we happen to get a line
which makes things a lot easier so these
2 X intercepts are pretty important and
this is y so if we have if we have here
this y-intercept is actually equal to 1
over the v-max
right here this B is the y-intercept
right so what we essentially have is we
have the y intercept is equal to
one over the view max so if we plot this
graph then and we find the y-intercept
we can calculate the v-max specifically
all we have to do is rearrange the
equation right here to V Max is equal to
1 over the y-intercept okay that's all
we'd have to do if we know the y
intercept them we basically know the V
Max the x-intercept is actually going to
be equal to 1 per to be negative 1 over
the km that negative is actually very
very important so we've won if we wanted
to and I'll show you why in just a
second the km essentially will be equal
to negative 1 over the x-intercept now
why is this negative value even here the
reason why is because notice that this
x-intercept is in the second quadrant so
that's going to be a negative value for
that x-intercept so if we're gonna have
a negative value we can't have a
negative value for km so that's why
actually this negative is here so that's
to cancel out so as to cancel out this
x-intercepts negative so we have a
negative and a negative that will cancel
we get a positive value for km because
the km value is always positive
specifically that's because the kms
units right are going to be equal to
substrate concentration right because
earlier we mentioned that the km is
defined or not or one of the sort of
definitions at least of km is it's the
substrate concentration at half of the
v-max so the km's units right our
substrate concentration so I'm actually
made a little a little note here so the
unit's right for each so we have km its
units our substrate concentration so
that could be anything it could be like
it could be micro molar it could be
molar it could be millimolar whatever it
is okay but it's some sort of
concentration okay so a concentration
unit what about what about V Max well V
Max is some sort of rate right so it
could be like micro mole moles per
minute it could be molar per second who
knows right excited as long as it's some
sort of concentration over time it's the
rate right so it's a rate so it's going
to be a concentration which I'm trying
to note here with the brackets it's
going to be a concentration
over time okay so that's a brief
introduction to the wine Weaver Burk
plot I hope that was helpful and and
pretty simple but so the important
things to keep in mind of course are
this equation and how they sort of how
it is graphed and it's important to
remember these these little equations
here so that if you're asked to
calculate the v-max or the or the km and
you know given these intercepts then
you'll be able to do it in addition this
slope here is equal to the came km over
the new max so if you know these
intercepts you can also find that all
you have to do is find the km find the
v-max and I just you know divide them
and get the slope okay so I hope that
was helpful in the next video I'll talk
about a few more things about the
language work line and I'll provide you
with an example I hope that was helpful
see in the next video